in occupied East Jerusalem many young
people are being lost to use of
synthetic cannabis commonly known as mr.
nice-guy and Palestinians here say that
Israel isn't doing enough to stop the
drug trade in their areas in 1987 masha
deluge opened the first drug
rehabilitation center in East Jerusalem
it's better and worse it's better
because we we started talking about the
problem before we keep it under under
the table we did not talk about it we've
been saying it's all over the world but
it's not in Palestine but it's worse
because there's more drugs available in
the streets now the beliefs they are not
innocent they are fighting us in this
way they don't want us to be awake they
don't want us to use our minds they want
to take to the houses of the Bible in
East Jerusalem and when you're using
drugs you will sell your mother
elsewhere in the center recovering
addicts describe their lives while using
Oh service de mañana de la dia and job
led man-woman de la dia was sudden
sneezed America had about obsidian on
Ibaka
one of our lesson bishop assets are
doing well as Amelia brouhaha but Lila
Poonam hands and nail militia zemenian
in order to stop the jobs from being
sold some Palestinians have resorted to
violence in a video released in February
on social media Palestinians in East
Jerusalem can be seen using sticks to
beat three alleged drug dealers the
attackers shout for them to leave the
area
gun shots can also be heard realizing
the problem is getting worse the
Jerusalem municipality recently hired
Palestinians to conduct drug prevention
workshops in East Jerusalem but many
anti-drug campaigners say their work is
being made more difficult by the lack of
opportunities facing young people in
East Jerusalem
unlike in West Jerusalem here in the
East there are few youth centers to keep
young people off the streets and those
that do exist are subject to Israel's
ongoing land expansion so for example
more than ten years ago
the Seoul and Sports Club on my right
had its play fields confiscated by this
Israeli settlement behind me my Mujibur
is a medical student who works at the
club in his free time he agreed to show
me around
I can to Lhasa I got any no Loschiavo ya
muhammad saw a valley yet fat board
crude cell can share a B&E when fish
mechanical very linear and canvas in a
frenetic passive alone and we should
have really had a filmic until our field
itself a when the Kanaka hockey nah man
I issue finally year to my second Avenue
at Norman jr. rod pulled up get a
permission emotional phallus toninho's
Durham
nakooma had sort national Hamlet which
would help all day duration lateral
Theory Filkins how to proceed with
tariffs keep the saw a job so I had my
song generosity realizations that
nanotech man ad Holly she can share
available auto I'm Canadian silouan a
hollow mr. lewin but Amidala share
wisdom we share a video based on mobile
we are again matter and energy near
Burma's an impersonal a hominid Shiva
daughter
zahana
Israeli officials say that fighting
drugs in East Jerusalem is made more
difficult because of the wall a product
of Israel's occupation but still that
doesn't stop authorities from cracking
down on political activities or
confiscating and destroying Palestinian
homes it's under such circumstances that
many here are determined to curb the
drug trade so that they can focus on the
everyday challenges facing Palestinians
some of the people take it to run away
from their problems they don't know that
they just stop thinking of that problem
when they take drugs
but the problem is still there and it
will come again and again